walked into my 18 year old neighbor when  he was taking a sales call and he hung  up the call and i was like you closed  the deal i already knew he hadn't closed  the deal i was like no i think he said  he's going to think about it he was like  why don't you think i'm closing deals  and i was like dude have you heard you  you sound like a stoned 18 year old no  one's gonna buy from you he's like well  how do i learn how to sell and i thought  there for a second and i was like dude  just join my sales team we'll show you  how to cold call we'll show you how to  close 12 months later kids making 200  000 a year as a 19 year old and the  thing is is it wasn't that sales didn't  work or the course that you had didn't  work is that you actually have to learn  the skill and the only way to do that is  through volume before we join my company  he was taking like one or two calls a  day as soon as he joined with us he was  doing 200 a day 100 times the effort 100  times the result